great movies can leave you laughing or
leave you crying but the test for me of
whether film is great is if it leaves
you humming this year's nominees for
Original Score I'll pass that test with
music that underscores enhances and in
at least one particular case does it so
skillfully that you wonder whether the
score was written for the script or if
it was the other way round here are the
nominees for Best Original Score lion by
Dustin O'Halloran and house come
Jackie by Mikah levy passengers by
Thomas Newman la-la-land
sighs Justin the with moonlight by
Nicolas the ten and the Oscar goes to
Justin her word lalala
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first Oscar win and third
nomination this year for Jepsen kurwa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay wow thank you so much to the
Academy thank you to my very very good
friend Damian I'm so glad I met you
thank you to mark Platt Jordan we're
with Fred burger thank you to everybody
Lionsgate thank you to all the LA
musicians who played on the score
I just put notes on a page and they're
the ones who made it beautiful and sound
the way it does
I start going through names I could make
at most 20 to 30 people happy but I'll
make about a hundred couple hundred
million people really bored so I'll just
leave it at everybody whose work is on
screen in any way in this movie I was
looking at your work when I was scoring
the picture I was looking at what you
did when I was scoring the picture and
that's what inspired me so thank you to
everybody who worked on on this movie
thank you
[Applause]